which podcast you'd like to download and
listen to afterwards while you travel
next on book tv investigative reporter
annie jacobson presents a history of the
military base area 51 located in the
nevada desert the author uses recently
declassified documents on-site reporting
and interviews with numerous people who
worked and lived at the base it's about
an hour
everyone and i wanted to thank the
commonwealth club for having me
and everyone for being here it's a real
author's dream to have a full house for
a book speaking event and thank you gil
for having me on your show and also for
moderating tonight and we'll get to some
questions because i i know people love
to ask questions i certainly do and i
wouldn't be here if i didn't have that
sense of curiosity so
um what i'm going to start with i'm
going to actually read you two
paragraphs from my book
but i'm going to set the
the stage so to speak a little bit first
and let you know where area 51 is other
than in people's imaginations because it
really does exist
and it's located in southern nevada
about 75 miles north of las vegas
it's in a much bigger
parcel of land that is the largest
federally restricted
piece of real estate in the united
states it's about the size of
connecticut
and it's called the nevada test and
training range
inside of the nevada test and training
range there's a
1350 square mile parcel
called the nevada test site and the
nevada test site is divided up into
quadrants the quadrant numbers have
changed and shifted and gone underground
over the years but
in essence they are 1 through 30 with
some mysteriously missing
area 51
sits just outside of the nevada test
site but inside the greater land parcel
that is the nevada test and training
range
and it is there that
many it is there that my book the basis
of my book centers and that is where
many of the
most secret and perhaps most alarming
uh national security projects took place
but also many of the most fantastic ones
that kept us all safe
arguably kept us out of world war iii
with the russians
certainly helped our pilots in vietnam
some really great things go went on
there and probably continued to go on
there today
but um
with that said i'm going to read you two
paragraphs in my book about
uh that really speak to what the book is
and and
when i was researching the book i was
able to interview a total of
74 men who had uh rare unprecedented
access to area 51.
32 of whom lived and worked at the base
for extended periods of time
and about 20 of them i kind of tell
their stories their characters in my
book and one of them that i'm going to
be reading about is a pilot a cia pilot
named ken collins and ken collins in
this scene is flying the
a12 ox cart
which is the was the cia's original mach
3
spy plane that flew at 90 000 feet so
mach 3 is three times the speed of sound
and 90 000 feet is about 17 miles up
and this was in the 1960s so it was
radical
science and technology at the time and
the spy plane was built
to take over after the u2
spy plane program was outed when gary
powers was shot down over the soviet
union
so i write
collins pushed the aircraft through mach
2.8 in another 45 seconds he would be
out of the danger zone
nearing 85 000 feet the inevitable tiny
black dots appear
began to appear on the aircraft
windshield sporadic at first like the
first drops of summer rain
only a few months earlier scientists at
area 51 had been baffled by those black
dots
they worried it was some kind of high
atmosphere corrosion until the mystery
was solved in the lab
it turned out the black spots were dead
bugs that were cycling around in the
upper atmosphere blasted into the jet
stream by the world's two superpowers
rally of thermonuclear bombs
the bugs were killed in the bomb's blast
and sent aloft to ninety 000 feet in the
ensuing mushroom clouds as they gained
orbit
when i first came across that detail i
found it incredible i thought to myself
what on earth or
that high up
are bugs doing dead bugs circling around
and i didn't really understand being 43
years old um
not having lived through the cold war to
the extent that many of my sources did
i i wondered well i was 40 when i
started the book but um i wondered
it didn't make much sense to me how why
these bugs were there and in essence
it's a bit of an analogy about what area
51 is
um
it was set up
to conduct espionage on the soviet union
the cia began building its base there in
1955
with the u2 spy plane because the cia
wanted to spy on russia and see what
they were doing
and
one of the other men that i interviewed
in my book was
hervey stockman and he just passed two
months ago which is
also a really interesting side note that
the men that i interviewed are really in
the last
chapter of their lives
but hervey stockman explained to me what
it was like to be the first man to fly
over the soviet union in a u-2
and yes he agitated nikita khrushchev
greatly and yes there was a lot of
fallout between the eisenhower
administration and the soviets over this
spying that was going on but at the same
time what hervy stockman brought back
in the film canisters of his u2
was over 400 000 square feet
of film of spy footage
about what was going on in the soviet
union and as hervey said to me
that the cia was able to learn and
understand that in fact the soviets were
not
lining up for world war iii as many
members of the air force wanted to
believe certainly general lemay who's a
character in my book as well you might
call him an antagonist
and so when you consider that the cia's
job is to present intelligence to the
president based on fact not fiction or
not speculation
that is what the u2 spy plane certainly
did for us
and i think that was an important
important notion
but at the same time there were other
elements of the government that were
really
pushing science as i write in the book
and i think here's where i get into
some of the more dangerous areas and
some of the questions that i
that i
would like readers to be able to ask of
themselves
about whether or not pushing science is
necessarily a good thing
right around that same time or actually
if you back up a bit you know for a
while after world war ii we had an
atomic bomb
and then
when we found out the russians were had
also had an atomic bomb this was in 1949
there was a big movement toward creating
a bigger bomb called the thermonuclear
bomb which is how these bugs got so high
up
and
robert oppenheimer the father of the
atomic bomb at the time really opposed
that on moral grounds he said it was not
a good idea to create a weapon that was
larger than its target
in other words the thermonuclear bomb is
so big that it would not wipe out a
military installation it would wipe out
a whole city
the thermonuclear bomb that
sent the bugs aloft that ken collins
flew through
was actually a thermonuclear bomb that
was 10 megatons
and that thermonuclear bomb is big
enough if it's dropped on manhattan it
would wipe out all five boroughs and it
would kill 75 percent of the population
down to washington dc over time so
obviously that's a bomb that's bigger
than its target
and
in my book i think
one of the more interesting analogies
that i came across was that
at area 51 here we were trying to
prevent
war so to speak that's what the cia was
doing with their espionage platforms and
on the other side of the fence over at
the atomic bombing range at the nevada
test site
the atomic energy commission and the
department of defense were practicing
how to have a nuclear war
this spy plane that ken collins was
flying was called the a12 ox cart and
although most people have probably never
heard of it because it was only
declassified by the cia
in
2007 50 years after
its drawings and one of the characters
in my book is the physicist who did
those original drawings and helped build
stealth for the cia
but this idea that you could have these
two
uh notions working at once is a little
bit complicated preventing a war but
practicing to have one
but what i the point i was making about
the ox cart was that
you probably have never seen it or or
heard of it maybe but its cousin is very
famous and that is the
i don't know if this is a military crowd
but it's the uh
uh sr 71 the air force's famous black
bird
um
that went mach3 and the sr-71 is
interesting because
it actually stood for originally
reconnaissance strike but president
johnson when he announced it bungled it
and they didn't want to correct the
president so they corrected the plane
but
reconnaissance strike meaning
so that when the air force decided to
take over the cia's espionage program
their idea was to have it
be
a spy plane that could go in and
photograph
a post-nuclear
site to figure out what to follow up the
bombing with
and i think that's one of the
more interesting parts or perhaps more
evocative parts of my book
that i hope people will read and think
about which is how these different
federal organizations that we have
work together
fight with one another on these secret
programs
that um
on balance perhaps keep us safer and
more more nationally secure but
sometimes enter into the area of
recklessness and i write about that in
the book also some of the weapons tests
that we did out there
were in my opinion reckless one of which
there was a program that we had called
project 57 and i tell the story through
the eyes of the security guard who
worked on that program he was also the
first security guard at area 51 during
the u2 program his name was richard
mingus but to work overtime so he could
buy a new car
he agreed to moonlight on this project
57 which was
the idea that the defense department had
well what would happen in america if
this was in
1957 by the way what would happen if one
of our planes carrying a nuclear weapon
were to crash on american soil
would it have an actual explosion would
it
create a kind of dirty bomb environment
they didn't know and they wanted to find
out
so at the very edges of area 51 in a
land parcel called area 13 they decided
to do what they called a safety test and
um in essence they they set off a dirty
bomb out there and they contaminated 895
acres
with plutonium that is still
contaminated out there um
so the idea of
what is keeping us safe what is pushing
science what is reckless
what is important
all kinds kind of comes together in what
i think is the enigma of area 51.
i could go on for a very long time i
wrote a 500 page book and it's filled
with stories but maybe to keep me on
track i'll uh take some questions from
the audience and uh we can start a
dialogue
we've got questions that are coming up
yeah no that's okay um
this is actually interesting because it
goes to a heart of your book a lot of
which is about secrecy and how off
budget this
operation was
a person asked what percentage of the
cia budget was area 51 and how is area
51 justified but you write in your book
that though the cia is certainly
running area 51
a large part of this and large part of
the most controversial things in your
book comes from the atomic energy
commission
that's right and the atomic energy
commission is now known as the
department of energy they've changed
their name four times over the years i
think to kind of
if you change the name of something
enough times maybe people will forget
about it um
but the original part of your question i
wanted to speak on that because it's
very interesting there's a one of the
people in my book that i write about at
length although he's passed so
everything that i've written about him
is from archives but he was the sort of
uh the first man to run area 51 for the
cia and his name was richard bissell and
he's famous in cia legend and lore for a
number of things but he
ultimately had to step down for
taking all the blame for the bay of pigs
and in my book i explain a little bit
that i think he got the bad rap on the
bay of pigs but so it goes when you work
in that kind of a business but uh asking
about where the budgets came from
i found out in my research richard
bissell was you know he was a brilliant
economist he was a yale graduate and he
became the executor of finance for the
marshall plan after world war ii so
there was something like 13 billion
dollars that was
at the disposal of richard bissell to
help rebuild
europe
and
a friend came knocking at his door one
night
in washington dc a man by the name of
frank wisner and the two sat in front of
bissell's fire place and wisner said you
know we need some money for this group
we have over at the cia
and because they had a mutual friend in
avril harriman
bissell
knew better than to ask many more
questions and just kind of agreed that
that would be all right and that
those funds were diverted over from the
marshall plan
to the cia about two and a half years
later bissell became the
uh subordinate to alan dulles the
director at the time of the cia and area
51 was up and running
okay several people want you to cut to
the little men
i told annie before we started that the
last time i saw the reverend ralph
abernathy he complained to me that he
wrote and it is if you ever get a chance
to read it a brilliant book in the
history of the civil rights movement and
all anyone wanted to ask him about was
one sentence about martin luther king's
personal life
so there's seven pages in this book and
and here come a bunch of questions
uh who what were the little men that
were seen at roswell
per the first chapter can you
comment on the ufo connection to area 51
what about the ufos and aliens what
about ufos
go for it annie
curious crowd no one wants to hear about
war and weapons um
when there's little green men to talk
about um okay but first i want to say
something about my sources because this
is important to me and it's important to
me as a journalist um
i interviewed a lot of men for this book
as gil said you know really the the
largest number of men that have ever
gone on record about area 51 and they
all go on record using their names
and there's one exception and that is
the source that i write about in the
last seven pages of my book that many
people want to know about
um
and this source remains anonymous for
reasons of safety and security and also
because
that program the program that he
discussed with me has not been
declassified per se
um
it's an interesting distinction as a
journalist to make between
being able to
source
your source's information up against
declassified documents
as i did with the first 367 pages of my
book
national archives
library of congress declassified
documents with cia with the atomic
energy commission department of defense
department of intelligence agency nro
nsa i can go on and on and on a lot of
late nights looking at documents
um and then there is a point in the book
where i
make a shift in the way i wrote the book
everything in the beginning is written
in a traditional journalist form where
you
annotate everything and you make clear
where your sources came from and in the
very end of the book i lean into the
reader who i trust has read my whole
book
and i say
okay but that's not why area 51 is still
classified
and area 51
has never been admitted to by any
organization in the government and
that's a fact they
any of the declassified documents always
have the word area 51 blacked out or
redacted sometimes they refer to it as
the test facility or the site
but it's only ever located in print
twice by me and i believe those were
obviously errors
um so why keep this base secret and i
lean into my reader and i say here's why
i think the base is secret and this came
to me from
a source
and in the last seven pages i tell you
what that source said to me and i'm very
clear to make clear that
there is no documents to fact check this
up against
while i did get some very
what i consider to be corroborating
suggestive evidence in archives
um the actual story is from one man's
oral history
the source was a engineer for eg g which
means that he had a top secret clearance
and also acute clearance for handling
nuclear secrets
and i examined the source's
medical records his war records
i looked at the
documents that he was the certificates
and awards that he was given by the
atomic energy commission
he worked for the commission across
three decades as a contractor he was a
member of the manhattan project
and the source told me that in 1951
he was one of five engineers that was
asked to solve what is called a wicked
engineering problem and a wicked
engineering problem means that it's
something that no one has figured out
and needs to be solved but solving that
problem will create its own new set of
problems
and the source told me that he was
one of five people who received the
equipment
from
wright-patterson air force base and that
was originally what crashed in roswell
and that it was a flying circular-shaped
aircraft it was not
from mars it was from russia
and
it was actually a
originally a third reich design
much of what i write about in the book
discusses how
a program called operation paperclip was
put into effect
after the war where
america
pillaged third reich scientists to head
up our aerospace programs and much of
our military programs werner von braun
is the best example he designed the v2
rocket for hitler he came over and
designed the apollo rockets for kennedy
but russia also did the same thing they
pillaged the scientists that they could
get their hands on
and so this flying disc according to the
engineer from egng
was something that had crashed in
new mexico and the intent was
for it to be a hoax
that stalin
and again were in 1947 here when we're
talking about the roswell crash
1947 stalin did not yet have an atomic
weapon truman did they were bitter
rivals
and so stalin
made a move
fired a warning shot over truman's bow
so to speak to say you may have the
atomic bomb but i have psychological
warfare
and a law the war of the worlds
he wanted to send this flying disc to
land in new mexico
and have
people come out that looked like aliens
and the eg g engineer told me
that the
child sized pilots inside were
the results of ghastly human experiments
in the soviet union
and that is what he told me and i repeat
it in my book because i wrote the
uncensored history of area 51 not the
censored history and many people
take umbrage with that certainly a
couple of the guys in my book aren't
happy about it and i understand why
as they've said to me you know we were
john wayne out there saving the free
world and no one likes to hear
about this kind of possibly this kind of
um ghastly goings-on in the desert but
this is what my source told me i
absolutely stand by his veracity and
it's what i wrote in the book and it's
obviously what a lot of people
um are very skeptical of and at the same
time want to know more about
if the
let me ask one one follow-up before we
get to the next one
so the reason then if it was not aliens
that would panic the population for
keeping this such a deep dark secret
would have been what
the reason for keeping the program
for keeping this particular program
essentially reverse engineering this
disc the idea that russians were doing
this psycops if they were caught
red-handed
why keep it a secret wouldn't that be a
victory look how awful stalin is look at
what they've done
uh there was evidence that he took some
of the papers that were captured from
joseph mengele
and
this would have been a great propaganda
victory for the united states
absolutely and that was
a question that i asked my source
repeatedly um
i interviewed him for over a hundred
hours across what i write in the book
was 18 months now it's been
more than two years
we would discuss nuclear weapons we
would discuss lots of things which i
would then go fact check
and at the end of our
several hour interview i would say can i
ask you another question about the
subject that we're not allowed to talk
about
and he would
say yes and that was one question i
asked often and
now remember keep in mind that this
individual
also participated in the program so he
was according to him a first-hand
witness
reverse engineered this craft
he received the people
um that were the child size aviators so
i asked him that question and he finally
gave me an answer which i write in the
book and he said because we were doing
the same thing
the idea that
the american scientists wanted to also
push science that they didn't want the
soviets ahead of us
in any program
whatever it may be
and i do want to say a note on that
because another journalist said to me
you know how dare you accuse the united
states government of such
horrible things and my answer to it was
and i spent quite a bit of time writing
about this in my book um while i don't
claim to
be able to speak for the technology in
the flying craft or
certainly the tech the the kind of
medical experiments that would
create that kind of a of an alien
looking person
what i do speak to and what i do write
about and what i do fact check and
source is what the atomic energy
commission did
during its tenure and the
reckless human experimentation that they
did there's you know president clinton
put together a commission in the 1990s
after a reporter named eileen wilson
revealed that the atomic energy
commission had been experimenting
injecting [ __ ] children with
plutonium at a state school in
massachusetts and you know i see all the
faces everyone's like oh god how
horrible and people really don't want to
hear about that and they they turn the
other way and they say
that's just horrible and kind of go on
and
you know i felt as a journalist that by
i believe what my source told me and i
believe that what he told me the reason
that he told me what he told me was
because it was a matter of conscience
the other four engineers are dead and so
it's just him he was very clear about
that and so if
a debate or a discussion
ensues
um as to whether or not this kind of a
program could go on
um how long it went on for
i feel that's an important discussion
and it's why i
chose to write about it in my book
you're listening to the commonwealth
club of california radio program our
guest today is annie jacobson los
angeles magazine columnist author of a
new book detailing her investigation of
the legendary military base known as
area 51. this question from the audience
if the contents and activities of area
51 are much less shocking than the
speculation all these years why do you
think the government maintains so much
secrecy about it
and i think we touched upon that as well
but i will also say that um
you know i take the reader all the way
up through the 80s one of the last
programs that i write about
uh was the f-117 bomber
the
that sort of diamond-shaped stealth
bomber that became famous in gulf war
one that was developed out at area 51
after the air force took over and sort
of replaced a lot of the camera bays
with weapons bays
but what has been going on since the war
on terror began
is a
is certainly out of my need to know and
um
and none of that i didn't have any
sources tell me what was really going on
there now
um because that really is obviously of
national security concern because we're
fighting the war on terror but it is
certainly a place where the drones are
test flow flown
and i also write another interesting
story from right about 1998
when
drones everyone's familiar with them now
because they're used in pakistan but
they began
as espionage platforms that only carried
cameras
um
they were actually used in the serbian
bosnian conflict
and they were just kind of not
interesting to many people other than
the cia but right around the late 90s
this unknown terrorist name osama bin
laden appeared on the scene
and the cia wanted to they were
considering assassinating him with a
with a drone and the way they would do
it was they would attach missiles to the
drone and this was kind of a radical
idea so they got together the cia and
the air force
and they decided to
engineer these hellfire missiles the
missiles are so accurate the hellfire
comes from fire and forget you just push
a button and it goes but first they had
to test it out there and the president's
concern at the time was well this osama
bin laden character is known to
do a lot of falcon hunting with members
of various middle eastern royal families
and
what if some somebody important is at
his compound when we attack him with
these
with this predator drone carrying a
hellfire missile that we don't know much
about we haven't used yet so they said
they built a mock-up of bin laden's
afghanistan farm which was called tarnac
farms and that's where they practiced um
how to possibly assassinate him without
collateral damage
this was before 9 11 but at the end of
the
at the end of the experiment the state
department got involved and there was
lots of legalities about assassinating
someone so they decided not to do it
so question how could area 51 secrets be
kept from american presidents
that's a very tricky and
uncomfortable question certainly for
this journalist
but
in the very beginning of the book i
explained to you that something that i
found really pretty shocking when i
learned it um
in researching this book that the atomic
energy commission actually has
a system of secret keeping that runs
parallel to the president's system of
secret keeping which is the national
security system
that is not the way the constitution was
written
but it is what the atomic energy act of
1946 allowed so when the charter was
written
right after world war ii for the atomic
energy commission
they created the system of secret
keeping which the slang for it is called
born classified
scholars who have looked into this
secret keeping system
say that it's
it allows the aec to have
unanswerable authority
and that is certainly the case and that
is why the atomic energy commission was
able to
do so many things the bomb test i told
you about that sent the bugs up to 90
000 feet
that thermonuclear bomb test
it involved 12 000 people in the middle
of the pacific ocean no one knew it was
going on when it went on
so
secret keeping is an important part of
area 51 for some reasons but it's also
not a good
situation for other reasons and it is
the source who tells me the story in the
end who told me that
um i asked him
you know
president clinton looked into the crimes
of the atomic energy commission
how come he didn't find out about this
rogue program at area 51 that involved
roswell and what he said to me was he
almost found out about it but he didn't
have a need to know
a question that goes back to
the ufo story
why would stalin send the craft to
roswell new mexico instead of a more
populated area
that's not an answer i have um
i'll ask the source i was kidding um no
i don't you know the thing that i write
in the end of the book is i'm very clear
about saying he said this and
according to the engineer um
there are some places in the epilogue
where i speculate about some things and
i
i go to some of my other sources and ask
them i asked the physicist okay
you know could we really have had a
stealthy flying disc the physicist ed
luvik who invented stealth for the cia
had an interesting answer which was that
he recalled sometime in the 1950s kelly
johnson who was the head of skunk works
who invented the
um who built those planes for the cia
kelly johnson had ed luvik radar tests
some round-shaped aircraft and at the
end of the day they decided that it just
wasn't it just wasn't you know
appropriate for a pilot to fly it was a
dangerous thing for a pilot to fly so
i you know i have as many questions as i
have answers actually i have more
questions than i have answers but i
don't have the answer to that one
although you write in the book the
roswell base uh air base was actually an
important base and of course white sands
los alamos i mean that was not an
unimportant area in terms of national
security oh it was the most important
area in the united states you had los
alamos you had sandia los alamos was
where the nuclear scientists were
working
sandia was where the weapons were being
assembled and roswell uh was the five of
the base of the 509th which was the
bomber group
you know one of the guys i interview in
the book is this amazing legend uh
colonel richard leghorn he's 92 now and
he's actually at home writing according
to his secretary he's at home writing a
paper on my book um
and he just did an interview with the
cape cod times talking all about his
role in my book and um he is
accredited in general with inventing
the concept of overhead
uh our first post-nuclear
post-war nuclear test
was a in 1946 it was in the pacific it
was called operation crossroads and
colonel leghorn was in charge of
photographing those bombs from the air
and in my interview with him it was
amazing because he explained to me all
about how
the base from which they left with all
the camera equipment was the roswell
army air base because
at the time that was the only
military base in the country that had
bombers that could actually carry
nuclear weapons so
that area of new mexico couldn't have
been more important to national security
in 1947.
if somebody wants to know if it's
possible and you answer this in the book
that many ufos were
actually were and are they right u.s
military aircraft that the united states
has been lying about
absolutely i mean one of the things that
i absolutely was able to source was the
cia's obsession with ufos starting in
the 1950s they actually even created
their own ufo
department and this is all based on
declassified documents it's funny to
read them read through them because the
see the guys at the cia in the 1950s
were really still
gentlemen spies they kind of fancied
themselves um
you know on the ground spies and this
idea of science and technology was a
little bit plebeian to them so you see
in all of these memos where they have to
deal with ufos they're saying you know
why can't the air force handle this
but in fact out at area 51 the u2 spy
plane accounted for over 50 percent of
all ufo sightings on the west coast
it flew at 70 000 feet which is about 13
miles up and when it was flying up in
the sky it looked like a giant silver
cross
and you can imagine people
on the ground seeing something up that
high would wonder
and then of course the same thing
happened in the 1960s when this
incredible cia spy plane called the ox
cart was flying at mach 3
even higher up
and there's a couple great accounts from
some of the guys in my book colonel
slater is one a real cold war hero
who i write about he was the commander
of the base for a number of years in the
sixties and he explained to me how often
commercial airline pilots would be
flying
on the west coast let's say at dusk
at thirty thousand feet
and they would see the ox cart fly over
overhead at ninety thousand feet at mach
three and people in the plane would see
it as well and they would the pilots
would radio in you know ufo ufo and
colonel slater would have to send the
fbi
to
wherever it was the plane was landing
and make the pilots and the people sign
inadvertent disclosure forms
letting them know they'd be in real
serious trouble if they told anyone
about that and these kind of things
certainly only added to the ufo lore and
mythology yeah plus i mean we have five
ox carts that crashed and of course the
as they went out to get the titanium
covers and all of that
obviously these kind of secret people
went out in in the desert and people saw
them and it all looked like they were
getting something very secret which was
but just not
flying saucer
which brings us to somebody asking why
in your opinion has area 51 become such
a popular element in u.s and global
popular culture
most assuredly because of the
conspiracies that are attached to it um
we've talked about the ufos um and the
aliens but there's two other big
conspiracy theories that are
sort of embedded themselves in area 51
they are that the lunar landing was
faked and filmed at area 51. that's a
big one
um i interviewed a lot of conspiracy
theorists for my book i also interviewed
buzz aldrin
the second man on the moon and i found
his testimony to be a little bit more
believable than the
some of the other people but that's just
the journalist in me
um
but there the thread the link there is
that
the
over at the nevada test site the
neighbor to area 51 there are these
giant craters
from the atomic bombs i was lucky enough
to go there
with a couple of the guys who were in my
book
and these atomic bomb craters are these
giant cavernous
you know things
that look very much like the surface of
the moon
and i interview a man named ernie
williams who actually was the tour guide
for the apollo astronauts
uh in the late 60s and early 70s they
would go out to the nevada test site and
put mock-ups on their back that they
would then you know that they would wear
on the moon when they finally went there
but they
the point was to kind of roam around the
geology of the
lunar landscape
and i have some great photographs in the
book of that
but i think that this gave way to some
of the conspiracies about
the lunar landing and another one i'll
touch upon was the
a lot of conspiracy theorists told me
that area 51 is
filled with underground tunnels and that
these
tunnels connect to other military bases
across the country what i found out was
there are a lot of underground tunnels
certainly at the nevada test site under
area 12 and 11.
um
one of the tunnels is 4500
feet deep that's
very deep
and starting in the late 1950s
the department of defense and the atomic
energy commission would use these
underground tunnels to explode nuclear
weapons
to see what would happen to different
pieces of military equipment to see what
could survive and what not so that's
where a lot of that mythology i believe
comes from
there's something you write in the book
that nobody's going to ask about unless
they've read the book but i think is
important before i take the next
question which is when we're talking
about some of the scientific
recklessness something that i had never
heard of before reading area 51 was we
did a
a high altitude thermonuclear test that
they knew in advance might endanger the
ozone layer they kind of just wanted to
see what would happen
true
when i first heard about this it really
made me wonder whether
you know when i was growing up in the
70s we were told that we couldn't use
aerosol deodorant anymore because it was
ruining the ozone and when i heard this
i thought i don't think it's the
deodorant
and what's what's really interesting is
i heard this story from the nuclear
weapons engineer who actually wired this
bomb
um
but there were two nuclear tests code
named teak and orange
and they actually took place down in
johnston island in the pacific
um
not at area 51 but the crew that worked
regularly at area 51 wiring nuclear
bombs went down there
and the idea uh the president's science
advisor at the time his name was james
killian
he had such
power and persuasion with the president
that
anything he did he did not have to
report to congress
later in his memoirs he admits that
maybe that wasn't a good idea
um but at the time
james killian authorized this
two-headed nuclear weapons test these
are megaton thermonuclear bombs
one was set off 28 miles up
the other was set off 50 miles up but 28
miles up is right around where the ozone
layer is
and
at the time there was i found in the
declassified documents there was
discussion among the scientists
what might happen
and could we make a hole in the ozone
layer this was an actual discussion
and the answer was
yes we could but
we believe the bomb turbulence would
then close back up that hole if it were
made and so they went ahead with the
test
there's a couple of questions from the
audience about sources
first one is if everyone's interviewed
is sworn to secrecy how is anything they
say valuable or believable and then a
variation on that do you have a top
secret clearance and if not what makes
you think these people you interviewed
told you the truth
um
what's interesting is some of the things
that i've been talking about like
the project 57 the dirty bomb test that
um spread plutonium over 895 acres up
there
uh people have said to me that i've
asked me that exact question you know
well that's actually not classified
those documents i located
in the atomic energy commission archives
i even located photographs but
it didn't look to me like anyone else
had looked at them
and i actually had a really difficult
time trying to find them
but once i
was able to
find someone who had
knowledge of that and knew it had been
declassified
i was able to talk freely with him about
that program and he was able to give me
some keywords that allowed me
to look up the program and access it
the program is called project 57 but
everything was classified under 57
project i mean
organized um so
all of the programs that i talk about
except for the program in the end
have actually been declassified it's
just that a lot of them are kind of
hidden or perhaps people weren't
interested in them in and of themselves
i think part of what makes
my book interesting is that i
try to give you the whole landscape of
area 51 and its nearest neighbors and
what was going on there
another one about uh
about the
aliens who
were according to your source not aliens
at all
were there autopsies done on the roswell
victims
according to his story too actually
lived but were in a coma
and why would their remains still remain
classified
the first part of the question was tell
me again the first part of the question
was were there autopsies
that i don't know um
they arrived as as bodies um
when they arrived according to my source
out at area 51 and they were comatose
but still breathing one of them died
shortly thereafter according to my
source
um
and the reason why the program is still
classified according to my source is
what we touched upon earlier that
the government decided to
embark upon its own program what i'm
also going to say at this point which is
interesting is that one of the most
interesting and disturbing pieces of
information that my source shared with
me was the individual who was the head
of the program his name was vanevar bush
and vannevar bush was in charge of the
manhattan project
he was the president science advisor and
he is the one who or you know was in in
charge of this program that really is
the mother of all black operations that
is the manhattan project and all other
black operations kind of trickle down
from that original idea in both analogy
and also secrecy
you also point out for people who wonder
whether something
could be kept secret
the manhattan project the size and the
budget amount and even the vice
president had no idea that the manhattan
project was underway i mean how many
people were working what was the budget
of that thing
it's in the book
um it was huge there was you know what
the where the
plutonium or the uranium at the time was
being processed um in tennessee
that outfit pulled more power
off of the united states electrical grid
on any given night than the entire city
of new york city
and yet no one knew it was there
that's how powerful a black operation
can be
the vice president that you're referring
to when the manhattan project was
originally going on was harry truman he
had no idea
about the nuclear weapon until he became
president
and the person who told him was van over
bush
basic question why name it area 51 are
there 1 through 50. if so explain
well that's the subject of a great
debate a lot of people even a lot of my
my named sources in the book will say oh
that's just a quadrant that they came up
with
but according to my source in the end of
the book
the reason that it is named area 51 is
because in 1951
the original equipment and the remains
of the roswell crash came there
you been called a conspiracy theorist
this audience member asked the net of
conspiracy theory has been cast so wide
it often includes investigative
reporters such as yourself in other
words you kind of get thrown in with the
3 a.m moons
i i'll let you guys decide on that one
but what i do know is that a lot you
know i've been accused of it i've
definitely been accused of being um
you know part of the government
conspiracy to hide aliens because my
theory does not
push the idea that aliens have visited
earth and i did get a letter from a
group or an email rather from a group in
the uk
furious with me last week when my book
first published they said even we don't
believe you
[Laughter]
the truth is still out there not here
why did area 51 show up in the wikileaks
document this person wants to know was
it only due to weapons testing or about
alien life or what that's news to me i
don't know about that so see me
afterwards
there was a and a lot of the book is
about we're talking about reverse
engineering because it
comes up and talking about roswell and
things one of the most significant parts
of the book and reverse engineering that
went on at area 51 one of the greatest
secrets was reverse engineering
the mig that was kind of hand delivered
for a million dollars by an iraqi pilot
to the israelis
it's a great story it's one of my
favorites in there and i tell it through
the eyes of t.d barnes who was a an
engineer who worked out at area 51 on a
number of projects
in 1966 your the story that you're
talking about made headlines when an
iraqi air force colonel named munir
redfa
defected from iraq to israel in a soviet
mig and at the time no one had no
western
you know no member of the western world
had ever had their hands on the soviet
mig it's what all the arab uh nations
flew and it's obviously what the soviets
the communist black countries flew so
the mossad got a hold of it it was a
very big deal to them it helped them win
the six day war
but what didn't make the news was that
after they were done with it they made a
deal with the cia
to bring munir redford's mig to area 51
and td barnes was on the team
that reverse engineered that mig they
took it down to its nuts and bolts and
looked at it to figure out what made it
fly
and at the time we were engaged in the
vietnam war and our pilots over there
were getting shot down in this terrible
ratio of nine to one we were really
losing against the mig
the soviets were supplying the north
vietnamese with the mig and so
there was a halt on the dogfights over
vietnam while the
engineers worked on the mig out there at
area 51
and after they reverse engineered it
that was called the technical phase then
they began what was called the tactical
phase so they put the mig back together
and they began flying it in dog fights
mock dog fights
in the skies over area 51 to figure out
how to beat the mig in air-to-air combat
and what is not known um until now or
kind of known only to the
the men who worked on that program is
that that was actually the birth of the
famous
top gun fighter school
there is there's another
thing that comes of that make being
there that almost outs area 51 and some
of the top secret projects there when a
general decides basically to go
joyriding in a mig that's right and it's
a pretty controversial story there was a
general who is in charge of the f-117
bomber program
out that was going on out at area 51 and
he became enamored uh with the mig
according to sources and he wanted to
take it for a flight and he did and um
the mig went out of control and crashed
in area 25 next door to it's about maybe
20 miles from area 51
and he where he crashed was right into
this place where another secret program
was going on
surprise surprise
and so at the time it was like my god
we've got the mig program we've got the
f-117 program we've got the nerva
program at area 25 we've got area 51
you know and you've got a general who's
dead
so
a newspaper reporter was leaked
information that the general had been
flying the mig and that program was
outed in that way and it allowed the
other secrets to remain hidden
there's a number of questions about the
advanced technology created at area 51
such as mach 3 speed aircrafts and why
this has not been released
commercially
questioner says it's odd that our
current commercial aircraft can only
travel at a fraction of this speed
compared to
what area 51 technology had half century
ago
are commercial aircrafts
you know i'm not an expert on jet
engines i did interview robert athernap
robert abernathy who developed the mach
3 engine for pratt and whitney and it
was super interesting talking to him um
about that but my understanding
would be and it's limited but that you
know it takes so much jet fuel to fly
mach 3 the
the ox cart spy plane was basically a
flying fuel tank it had the delta shaped
wing that was just filled with fuel
it could get from one coast to the other
coast in a little over 60 minutes
so i don't think that would be cost
effective
on a commercial airline and you would
not really have any place to put your
bags
plus all that mid-air refueling yes
mid-air refueling is tricky too um
yeah and then a couple of planes were
lost yes and stories that you tell in
the book
oh well i'm going to say one of the
things you know the the
i became a big fan of the cia's science
and technology department i must say
because the things that they did out
there and they did it in total secrecy
without getting any any credit for it
but to refuel the ox cart it was such a
incredibly fast flying plane the ox cart
had to fly
at it at its absolutely slowest speed
and the fuel tanker had to fly at its
fastest speed
you know at the same time and uh
you know the plane the ox cart would
sometimes almost stall that's how slow
it had to go
um somebody in the audience says why do
you think the government was prompted to
declassify all of this stuff and provide
great stuff for your book
well that's also an interesting question
they didn't declassify all this stuff
they declassified the a12 ox cart in
2007 and i don't know why um i've asked
some
people at langley why and they have
different different answers none of
which
really answer the question um because if
you're trying to keep a base secret it
would make sense not to declassify one
of the major programs there uh
but that is how i was able to
speak to ed luvik who was the original
source and that is how i was introduced
one to the next to the next of all the
different sources who
um
make up the narrative of my book and to
whom i'm very grateful because you know
it was a real honor and a privilege to
be able to
talk to these men
who
are really a group of cold war heroes
scientists spies engineers physicists
who were known only among themselves
and now i think
in reading the book you're able to see
a really have a really interesting
window into what it's like to be someone
who
does all this work for absolutely no
glory
there is a story you tell in the book
that people have to read the book to
know that is possibly the most
frightening
well there's many frightening parts of
the book
and it is a staged attack
on area 51 to test the perimeters for
security even though it was secret to
many americans the russians had known
about this place since forever
and uh watched it by satellites and so
they decided to test the security
if i understand it from your book
correctly without telling anybody at
area 51
and
during the time of a nuclear test
that's right and the way that i was able
to put that story together was very
interesting because the actual mock
attack on the guard gated area 51 by
whack and hot security guards is still
classified
but what isn't classified is the fact
that these nuclear weapons test
engineers on the other side of the fence
were working to get a nuclear bomb down
into a shaft so that they could explode
it on a weapons test
and so the story came from the guys who
were over on the other side of the fence
who were working on the nuclear bomb not
from the guys at area 51 who can't talk
about it um but what happened was
there was this weapons test going on and
you they measure
they measure the system of measurement
to get a bomb down into its hole is
picked so it's like you know x number of
yards means it's this pick and it has to
get to a certain depth before it's
considered secured otherwise it could
still in essence be hijacked and so
there's different layers of security
that are watching this bomb go down and
the gentleman who is in charge of the
program is my um source in the book
richard mingus he was in charge of it
and there he is waiting for the thing to
get down the thing the nuclear bomb to
get down the hole and he hears suddenly
were under attack
and they had to treat that as if the
russians were attacking or an enemy
force was attacking because
it made no sense otherwise but as it
turned out
it was actually a test by the security
people who wanted to see what it would
be like
uh how the guards at the area 51 gate
would respond to an attack and so they
flew a helicopter over the guard gate
and were you know mock shooting at it
the alert went all the way to the white
house and according to the source um the
the nuclear subs on the west coast were
also put on alert
i'll sleep better hearing that um
and with a live
nuclear weapon in the hole yes at that
time and the test went on by the way
number of questions from people
saying many of uh here's one of the many
of the united states military projects
born or developed near a51 including the
f-117 stealth fighter
was the blackhawk helicopter used in the
osama bin laden raid
developed at area 51
i would certainly like to know that but
i don't have a need to know about that
yet
sounds like it would be a great place to
uh fly those helicopters or practice
that
weather technology developed there going
going it's kind of a variation on the
previous question about the aircraft
whether the technology there so you know
the famous questions about teflon and in
the space whether the technology there
so you know the famous questions about
teflon and
in the space program and all of that has
gotten out into the commercial world at
all or whether what's developed there is
just so secret
what what's developed at area 51 stays
at area 51 that's a really interesting
question and i don't i haven't heard
about any um commercial applications it
tends to be
military and espionage based
including the stealth paint and
all of that yes the first attempt of
which
was apparently according to the book
something of a disaster
yes they tried to
originally make the u2 stealthy
um because when the pilots like hervey
stockman and immediately were flying
over the soviet union the soviets were
able to track them right away
um they couldn't shoot them down because
they were so high up but the physicist
ed luvik was called on board to try and
make the u2 stealthy it didn't work and
one of the pilots was killed out there
flying one of the planes that had been
doctored up with some some paint that
was supposed to be camouflaged and
instead it made the plane overheat
unfortunately we've reached one of our
program where there's time for only one
last question
and uh somebody kind of open-ended for
you
was there one particular story that you
found the most shocking or surprising of
the things you learned about area 51
you know everything that was told to me
was
very ornate and very interesting and i
think
all circled back to allow
me to create
the puzzle so to speak the all these
individual pieces that in and of
themselves were fascinating
to understand the broader bigger picture
of area 51
was what i found the most rewarding
certainly at the end to step back and
say this makes sense and this is this
this is why it's secret and this is what
went on there even though i probably
only know a small fraction of it um
winston churchill once said about and he
was speaking about russia he said it's
an enigma wrapped inside of a puzzle
wrapped inside of a riddle
and
he could have been speaking about area
51.
our thanks andy jacobson los angeles
magazine columnist
author of the new book area 51 and
uncensored history of america's top
secret military base
this event was hosted by the
commonwealth club of california in san
francisco for more information visit
commonwealthclub.org
we'd like to hear from you